hello everyone and welcome to the
continuation of the gold money asian
rapid knockout we are now in the
semi-finals and
the four semi-finalists are vladislav
being clear and magnus crossing and
levon are none and
the first game we're going to cover is
actually the third game from the match
vladislav artemy versus being lyran
uh the match uh started out pretty equal
the first game ended in a draw then the
second the game uh was won by dean liran
and now vladislav needs a win to bonds
back
so can he work his magic like he did
against anishigiri or is
ding maybe uh in to too good of a form
because
that often it will be
dingy either plays extremely well or he
is just unstoppable so let's see what
happens here
with knight to f3 uh uh our team of
going for
for the red opening with d5 uh g3
knight g3 knight to f6 we have bishop to
g2 and c5 now
so the uh sicilian variation of the
king's indian attack
we have castles and e6 now uh we have d3
bishop to e7 and the white attacks in
the center with
e4 uh and here it's a quite a known
position but it hasn't been played all
that many times there is one
very notable game in the database uh
where knight the c6 was played cardiac
and played
this and he defeated peter svidler in
the 2014 candidates tournament
but here we have castles biting and it
is already as of most six that we have a
completely new game
uh we have queen to e2 uh and now knight
to c6 so just continuing development
with
a4 uh and d captures on e4 we have d
captures on e4 and e5 now so you can
develop your light square bishop to e6
we have c3 by white
now controlling this knight here on c6
uh and now
uh developing the bishop to g4 wouldn't
really make all that much sense
the queen can always move this since the
bishop already guards the knight and you
don't have access to these squares
uh to maybe jump in with your knight so
you can maybe uh pile up on this knight
so bishop g4
wouldn't really make all that much sense
here so bishop to e6 uh seemingly the
more active move
knight b to d2 and now queen to c7 we
have knight to c for now
uh with a double attack on this pawn
here but also it's just a very nice
square for the knight
if black wants to get rid of it he's
gonna have to give up his light square
bishop so here
rook a to d8 and now knight to g5
trying to get rid of black's bishop pair
white want to
capture wants to capture here on e6 so
bishop to g4
attacks the queen and artemis just
defends with f3 ding has to go all the
way back and
now f4 so artemia really uh doing well
here and his pieces are uh pretty much
all assuming optimal squares you you
still have to develop your dark square
bishop connect the rooks but other than
that your position is uh looking great
so bishop back to g4 we have to take the
the space left behind and now
queen to c2 we have h6 uh kicking away
the knight and not
knight back to f3 and only now e
captures an f4 and now
uh ding was able to to mess up artemis
pawn structure in front of the king a
little bit
g captures on f4 and now bishop to e6
uh you could also play bishop captures
uh instead of g capture so which doesn't
ruin your pawn structure
but it's um you know not nothing much to
look at for white and artemis is already
losing the match he has to bounce back
so
here after for example queen theatre
queen to d7 uh
black um doesn't have all that many
active ideas here at least he
uh brings a little bit of an unbalance
into the position and now
he has these pawns here controlling a
lot of squares he can push them he can
do some damage maybe
so here bishop back to e6 biting
attacking the knight here and now
b3 defending and not knight to h5 with a
double attack here on the f4 pawn
so e5 uh blocking the queen's attack to
the pawn here and now queen to d7
uh we have knight after d2 now shifting
the knight to e4 as this square was now
freed so you can get the knight all the
way to d6 or maybe even f6 and sound
lines
we have f5 biting now taking away the
square from the knight and
now uh well you could capture here alpha
song yeah it's
nothing really all that dangerous after
knight e4 the rook can come to g6
and now it's uh well it's actually black
who's attacking
so instead after f5 we have queen to d1
now
remaneuvering the queen with the
pressure on this knight here
and now queen to e8 defending the knight
while exposing the d
file to the black rook we have queen to
e2 now
on pinning and now g5 ding
knows that this is how you have to play
this uh uh
you're going to weaken the e5 pawn and
you're going to break through the
position here
so f captures on g5 h captures on g5 now
ding has two
very very strong pawns here uh that he's
ready to push in front of artemis king
we have
knight to f3 uh with a double attack on
the g5 pawn but the ding of course just
defends it with queen to g6
uh and now knight to d6 a very tricky
move
you want to get rid of one of the
defenders of the g5 square so if
if you go for this capture and then
capture here we can just capture on g5
and then white position is much much
better than it was um
if this wasn't played but luckily this
wasn't played uh
in the game after night the d6 ding just
continued pushing he played
g4 now comes knights the e1 and now
f4 so those pawns are now monsters and
well uh you just know that f3 is coming
at any moment
so here bishop to e4 not allowing this
double attack to occur
the queen back to g7 and now knight
captures on b7
uh just boldly grabs this pawn attacks
the rook
and he says all right now you're going
to move the rook then i'm going to bring
the knight back
but the ding doesn't ding just plays
knight captures on e5 he removes the
defender of the d6 square
and now the knight doesn't really have a
a better option than to capture the rook
on d8
so here knight capture 78 was played we
have bishop captures on d8
and now uh here comes a very nice move
and that is knight
to d3 uh but this is only nice uh
because uh well it it doesn't work uh so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the deadliest possible
uh win here for black while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not playing f3
f3 is very nice and you will win the
game but it's not
as deadly as the move i'm going to show
you
uh just to show you f3 uh the problem is
we can play bishop to h7 with white and
this kind of gives the black a lot of
hope doesn't matter what you capture the
bishop with
uh we can always just pick up this
knight here and now the the queen is
defended and
although black is still much better you
will still have to work for your meal
uh for for some 20 30 moves who knows uh
so instead
knight to f3 that's the good stuff this
comes with to check
and now of course the knight cannot be
captured if it's captured then
the white king is in check and the queen
is attacked you're going to lose the
queen here
so instead after this check we have king
to g2 but now comes
knight to h4 with check king to g1
and now only now f3 is now this is much
much stronger
so what do you play here here we have
the same idea bishop to h7 check so the
bishop on e6 will fall
but it doesn't matter king captures
queen captures and then now comes
g3 so the queens are still on the board
and the ding is just
enjoying his attack very much so uh what
do you play here
uh not a lot of options here for white
queen to e4 check was played we have
rook to f5 ding just blocks this and
again how do you continue
we have rook to a2 adding some support
to the second rank but
uh just g captures on h2 a double check
so the king has to move
uh or capture on h2 uh so king captures
and now bishop the c7 check all of
link's pieces
are piling up on white's king and now if
you go king to h1 we can just play
knight g3 check
you'll lose the queen and you will get
checkmated very soon
so instead knights the f4 was played
blocking this check but as you can see
this is also
uh completely unplayable knight captures
on f4 was played
bishop uh first bishop captures it then
comes bishop captures with
czech king to h1 and now queen to g3
and here you you really don't have um uh
any any good moves uh
i ideas like knight the g dude then
followed by queen to h2 checkmate are
coming
uh or you can just play uh well you
can't move the rook since the rook is
pinned but you really don't need to
there's uh
there's enough to do without the rook so
here queen the queen the e7 check artemi
tried checking a few more moves king h6
queen e6
check king the h5 now queen eight check
but now we block
knight the g6 and now uh you can even
play some like
king to g4 and then bring the rook over
to h5 you don't even have to worry about
rook to g1
it's such a such a good position but not
while the knight is hanging obviously
but there are many things you can do
here
so here rook if the f2 was played really
trying to grab hold of that second rank
but
just king to h6 now black on pinned and
now the knight can also move we
rook the h2 with check but now rook the
h5 as the h5 square was now freed for
the rook we have rook captures king
captures
uh and the queen to e6 uh so here you
again can win in a lot of ways f2 wins a
king to h6 was played in the game
so queen to e4 and now we have f2
uh now the the rook's defense of the h2
pawn head of the h2 square has been
blocked now queen to h2 is the threat of
checkmate
queen the g2 was played here but now
dean just played queen to h4
and he was in this position on move 50
that vladislavia resigned the game
and another excellent victory for dean
lyron who by winning both the game two
in the game three and drawing uh the
first game
uh wins the first match so artemi will
have his work cut out for him tomorrow
he will have to be being in the first
four rapid games the fourth tie breaks
and then hope uh
uh you know of doing well and then
reaching the finals
uh so now like i said uh ding either
does uh extremely well or or he's
unstoppable and here uh it seems just
that he was unstoppable and it seems
that it's really going his way since
most of these tournaments he had to play
like
really really early in the morning like
i think he started like 2 a.m and then
he played until maybe
five or six which is uh okay i know you
can get accustomed to it but
um you know everyone else was playing
like in normal time zones
but for chess players i know any time
zone is a normal time zone
you can play chess whenever you want but
still he didn't seem to do all that
great even though
he claimed that it did not affect him
but here he's playing in normal time and
he seems to be doing
doing really really well uh so we'll see
if he will be able to beat artemiv and
grab a spot in the final uh so that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank leander
moderators on constantino buchi
vladolaro
uh locustocaris and melanie peters for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh with a game uh from the other match
magnus vs levon uh so stay tuned for
that
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day